[Music]
all right welcome back
we're talking about complex analysis
which is the study of complex numbers
complex variables and functions of these
complex variables
and one of the most important
properties of all complex
numbers is kind of this relationship
between this cartesian form and this
polar form
of that complex number which is very
very
kind of elegantly represented by by
euler's formula e to the i theta equals
cos theta plus i sine of theta
so today this is such an important
concept i'm actually going to derive
this today using the taylor series for
the exponential function e to the z and
we're going to you know relate it uh to
what we have already been learning about
complex numbers
and especially how these complex
functions are used in the solutions of
ordinary and partial differential
equations okay so i feel like complex
analysis is a little bit of a wilderness
so that's why i didn't shave today
because we're going into the wilderness
of complex functions
uh let's get started this is one of the
coolest things um
in uh
in math okay so we're going to take the
um
complex let's say let's say the taylor
series for e to the z
that can be written as um
this sum let's say the sum
uh from
k equals zero to infinity of z to the
power k
divided by k
factorial this is just a really really
efficient way of writing down the taylor
series of my exponential function this
doesn't have to be a complex exponential
this is true for the real exponential
but it's also true for the complex
exponential so this is going to be a
theme uh in in a lot of the following
lectures when we start thinking about
functions of a complex variable
we're basically going to take functions
of a real variable like sine of x cosine
of x e to the x you know logarithm of x
we're going to write down the taylor
series you know the real value taylor
series that we're used to and then we're
going to act we're just going to plug in
a complex variable into that argument
and expand things out and see what
happens okay so that's a valid thing to
do
and you know this would equal something
like uh i hope i don't mess this up you
know it's like 1 plus x plus
x squared over 2 factorial is just 2
plus x cubed over 3 factorial which is 3
times 2 which is 6
plus x to the fourth over 4 factorial
plus dot dot dot okay um
maybe i'll write at least one more term
i think i need a couple of odd and a
couple of even terms here you know plus
uh
x to the fifth over five factorial plus
dot dot dot
good
and that goes on for forever and ever
and ever
and so you know you might think that
this blows up because x to the fifth and
x to the sixth get bigger and bigger if
x is bigger than one but dividing by
this factorial kind of keeps that that
sum bounded
and if you wanted you could actually
compute the radius of convergence of
this taylor series
and you would find that the radius of
convergence is you know essentially
infinite any any finite valued x this
will converge
because dividing by factorial factorials
growth so quickly that this thing you
know the series kind of decays okay
but that's not what this lecture is
about what we're going to do now is
we're going to take uh these should have
been z's i'm sorry these are all
let's say this is uh e to the x
is equal to
this is what we're used to from the real
valued taylor series of the exponential
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to replace this real variable x
with our complex variable z okay that's
what we're going to do now
so now and i think i'll switch to blue
so now what i have is
e to the z
it's going to get a little gnarly uh
equals
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to plug in i theta because we're not
trying to we're not trying to show what
e to the z equals we're trying to show
what e to the i theta equals
so e
to the i
theta
equals now every term x here i'm going
to replace it with i theta so this
equals 1
plus i theta
plus i theta quantity squared over 2
factorial
plus uh i theta quantity cubed over
three factorial plus i and i'll go up to
fifth order just like before
four over four factorial plus i theta
quantity
to the fifth power over five factorial
plus dot dot dot dot
uh you know plus i
theta to the k power over k factorial
plus dot dot dot to infinity okay
this is pretty straightforward we just
took the taylor series of the
exponential function plugged in i theta
for the argument
and now what we're going to get to do is
you know i think you're already going to
see
some of these terms
have an imaginary coefficient some of
them have a real coefficient
and for example i squared we know is the
real number negative one so you know
this is going to be real
the fourth power is going to be real the
sixth power is going to be real
and the odd powers the one the three the
five the seven those powers are going to
be imaginary so i'm going to be able to
split this into real parts and imaginary
parts good
and we're going to use the fact that um
you know i
to the one power equals i
i squared equals negative one
i cubed is just i times i squared so
that's minus i
i to the fourth is i times i cubed which
is minus i squared
which is plus one
and then it repeats i to the fifth
equals
uh
i
and so on and so forth okay so this is
kind of the pattern of what happens when
you take i to different powers
and we're going to use that to kind of
split this up into different pieces
so this equals
one
maybe i'll just do all of the i terms in
pink
plus i
theta
plus i squared theta squared i squared
is just negative one so that's minus
theta squared over 2 factorial
i cubed is minus i so that's minus i
theta cubed over 3 factorial so all of
the blue terms are real all of the pink
terms are imaginary
similarly i to the fourth is just plus
one so that's plus
theta to the fourth over four factorial
this would be
i to the fifth is just i so that's plus
i theta to the fifth over five factorial
plus dot dot dot dot
and so essentially now what we have is
we see e to the i theta because this
expansion has all terms of even and odd
powers
i get the
odd
the
even terms are real because i to an even
power
is real
and the odd terms are imaginary because
i to the
odd power is imaginary let me let me see
if i said this right
in this taylor series of e to the x i
have you know odd powers you know x to
the one x to the three x to the 5. all
of those when i plug in i theta are
going to give me you know an imaginary
i'm going to have a little i left over
all the odd powers have an i in them
and all of the even power is like 1
that's just x to the 0 you know x
squared x to the 4th x to the 6th those
are actually going to be real valued the
i's go away when i take i to an even
power
and so now i can split this up into just
the real parts
minus theta squared over 2 factorial
plus
theta to the fourth over 4 factorial
plus dot dot dot
plus
i times all of these pink terms which is
theta minus
theta cubed over three factorial plus
theta to the fifth over five factorial
minus dot dot
and hopefully you recognize from kind of
uh you know your early calculus class
this is this even expansion here this is
the taylor series expansion for cosine
of theta
so this is literally cosine
and all of these pink terms here these
odd functions here
this is plus i times
this whole thing is sine
of theta
and so essentially what we've just kind
of demonstrated or proven is that e to
the i theta equals
cosine of theta the real part is cosine
of theta
plus i times sine theta the imaginary
part of this function is sine theta
and that's euler's formula one of the
most important formulas
definitely in complex analysis this is
the you know the cornerstone formula for
all of complex analysis is this here but
it's also essential when we think about
ordinary and partial differential
equations so when i teach my math class
at university of washington
and i'm dealing with anything involving
oscillations ordinary differential
equations partial differential equations
fourier series uh fourier transforms the
first thing i do is i derive
uh euler's formula using the taylor
series for e to the z or e to the x or
whatever you want to call it and when
you plug in i theta for that argument
you find that this expansion half of the
terms are real and half of the terms are
imaginary and the real terms add up to
cosine of theta and the imaginary terms
add up to i sine of theta extremely
extremely extremely important
okay
[Music]
and it's kind of interesting right this
is where that uh like the magic formula
of mathematics right e to the
i
this is one of the weirdest and most
interesting formulas in all of
mathematics you take you know e which
has to do with compound interest
pi which has to do with you know uh the
ratio of a circumference to the diameter
of a circle and i which is the square
root of negative one these three like
bizarre numbers when you take e to the i
pi
if i plug in pi here cosine of pi is
negative one and sine of pi is zero
so this just equals negative one
this is one of the weirdest uh
relationships in all of math but it is
kind of trivial when you know euler's
formula and when you know where euler's
formula comes from okay
so we're going to use this all the time
and what we're going to find for example
when we solve ordinary or partial
differential equations when we say
you know we know that the motion of this
pendulum is something like
theta double dot plus theta equals zero
or we know that the mass the spring mass
damper has a dynamics like y double dot
uh you know plus y equals zero something
like that
what we're going to find is that the
eigenvalues of these differential
equations are going to be complex
numbers like you know plus and minus i
and the solutions
of those functions then are going to be
something like e to the plus or minus i
t
and so that means that the the mass you
know the position of the mass the
vertical position of this mass is going
to be given by the real part cosine
in this case cosine of t
and the velocity of this mass is going
to be given by the imaginary part sine
of t okay so in my differential
equations portion of this class you'll
see this formula come up over and over
and over again because the solutions of
these ordinary and partial differential
equations
are written in terms of things like e to
the i t or e to the minus i t
and we need to look at the real part and
the imaginary part to give the position
and the velocities
of these moving oscillating quantities
okay
if that was a little fast or went a
little over your head that's okay
there's a whole class on differential
equations where we find out how these
functions are the solutions of these
differential equations but again you're
going to be relying on knowing that this
quantity this formula euler's formula is
true
okay last thing i want to show you is
kind of a neat uh
almost like a corollary of euler's
formula something called i think it's
called de moivre's
de moivre i'm doing this completely off
of memory so i'm probably butchering
this i think this is like you know the
moir pattern um
i'm making up that connection but de
moff's uh
relationship or theorem
is essentially that if i take um
[Music]
cosine
theta
plus i sine
and i take that to the nth power this is
going to seem like i'm making this up if
i take this to the nth power
that equals cosine
of n theta
plus i sine of n
theta
which is really really weird if you take
this expression
and you actually multiply it by itself n
times and you do the polynomial
multiplication you'll get a bajillion
terms it'll look like pascal's triangle
of terms
and what i'm claiming what de moivre
claimed is that that huge expansion of
this to the nth power all of those terms
simplify
and what ends up is you just get a
cosine of n theta plus i sine of n theta
that seems really
bonkers and out there but it's actually
super simple to show if you know euler's
formula
i know that this
is this cosine theta plus i sine theta
is just e to the i theta
and if i take that to the nth power
e to the i theta to the nth power is
just e to the i
n theta and e to the i n theta is just
cosine of n theta plus i sine of n theta
so this is a really really useful
formula also it essentially says that if
i take a complex number z to the nth
power
the phase angle theta just gets
multiplied by n that's a really really
useful property and that's de moivre's
formula here
okay good we're going to use this
everywhere euler's formula for me is
kind of one of those things if someone
shakes you awake at two in the morning
you're on a desert island and someone
shakes you awake
in the in the middle of the night you
should be able to not only write down
euler's formula but derive it from
scratch in the sand if you had to okay
this is cornerstone mathematics right
here and we're going to use it all the
time when we think about complex
functions we're going to use it all the
time when we think about the solutions
of odes and pdes that have anything
oscillatory like a guitar string or a
pendulum or a mass
on a spring
okay thank you